where's the the box honey samosa mm-hmm
your new nose huh cheers to that
Cheers same to same cheers well this is
like eating a mango tastes like Martha
yeah it is mother no my mom will eat
five mangos a day when carries come when
we have carries I hide it for my
brothers I think I will eat that
Pakistani Indian mango is that good -
you can have some OSes without chutney
no you can't know I need my chutney
I've lived in Pakistan for 15 years and
this was like a staple in my diet let's
try it yeah that's right this is your
mind superstars
lot of rice for this pop star than me
really it's right up yes man my mom used
to put peas also in samosas so it's like
I feel like that's a bug exciting thing
to do that's the trademark recipe for
samosa potatoes and peas right yeah
there you go exactly muna I mean I've
seen it with meat in it but like they're
like smaller I'm pretty confident I'm
gonna say this one is Indian I would
also agree with that I knew it I knew
these were the one oh you're right yeah
yeah it's crazy
even though I'm with Cindy I've never
tried to Cindy dyani before my mom makes
pull out too though hmm
folks it was good I feel like she has
done it like that but she's gonna like
that too I feel like India has a lot
more spices into it so I'm gonna say
this isn't Heather body if I get this
wrong I'm Heather body so it's so what
is it this one is this anyone I guess I
thought this was Heather your body my
parents never made this for me you guys
really know what you're doing yeah
thanks
I can't start my day without a good cup
yeah you know what I need to try
throughout the day I carry this one
looks just like India although each I
would take rest with my mom
have you heard about the child he was
just standing there like serving Chaya
on the street right and his pitcher was
like this
his eyes kind of like Pierce into like
my insides and I'm looking I mean let's
be real he's hot but yeah yeah dude Jai
brings everyone together sometimes my
parents low light and then like an hour
later there'll be like a what the Jaya
or not it's all good time though at the
time
you know overall do you still hate me I
have never had a single drop of hatred
in my heart for you I like that
same here my family's from a my and then
my family's from Karachi and I would
have never known that you were Indian I
cannot speak in Hindi with so many other
Indians because they have their local
state languages but then with Pakistan I
can clearly converse in Hindi we all
love Bollywood yes we do if you're in
India you will still watch pump so far
and then I'm used to fit all those like
other like you know exactly psyche and
also brings us together Molly Briana is
Cindy Brioni yeah you know bar sign
jalebi Indian Julia bhi the same you
don't go to a party and say this one's
Indian this one enjoy it it brings
everyone together yeah like there was
both green in the colors the flags oh
wow he's like Oh Johnny by John it
showed the to Pakistan India a friend
United hypnotist talked about Salman
Khan